welcome back to cbs this morning
hurricane sally is expected to make
landfall as a category one tomorrow
producing heavy rain and a potentially
life-threatening storm surge states of
emergency have already been declared in
mississippi
alabama and louisiana and manuel barcas
is in biloxi mississippi for us manny
good morning to you
what's it feel like there well it
definitely
is starting to get worse the weather
here in biloxi and i can tell you that
the window to evacuate some of these
low-lying
areas will begin to close later today
and that includes here where the storm
surge
could be up to nine feet the city of
biloxi declared a state
of emergency and opened up sandbag
locations for residents who would like
to shore up their properties some told
us that they saw the forecast track
and they realize this is not the kind of
storm that they want to take
any chances with what is perhaps most
telling
is the fact that the fire department
here is preparing
for water rescues and that's because yes
the winds will be something to contend
with
as the storm comes ashore but they're
really concerned about the combination
of the storm surge the heavy rainfall
and the fact that the storm could just
hover
over this area for quite some time that
could likely
lead to life-threatening flooding not
just here
in biloxi but across a wide swath of the
gulf coast
gail thank you manuel